[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back I was Harry she was Sally
and now we meet again the scene we did
together in a deli brought new meaning
to the term happy meal and I have never
had to fake my admiration for her I'll
have what she's having any time please
welcome a great actress miss meg Ryan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our directors are a combination of
talented architect imaginative designers
skilled sketch artists educated shopper
tasteful decorator astute businessperson
and shrewd diplomat here is a brief peek
at those nominated this year for best
achievement in art direction the cold
and austere look of the future is
captured in Gattaca by art director Yan
Roth's
and Nancy knife or her set decoration in
Kundu the timeless and haunting mystique
of Tibet is embodied in the art
direction of Dante Ferretti and set
decoration by Francesca lo Schiavo the
gritty look of Los Angeles in the 50s is
evoked in LA Confidential by the art
direction of Jeanine Opel wall set
decoration by JR Hart
both the characters and the sets of men
in black become otherworldly with the
art direction of Bo Welsh and the set
decoration by Cheryl classic the
monumental task of bringing back a
sunken ship in all its exquisite detail
was accomplished for Titanic by art
director Peter Lamont set decoration by
Michael Ford and the Oscar goes to
Peter Lamont for Sarah
[Applause]
[Music]
Peter the Martin Michael Ford have a
combined total of eight Oscar nomination
for work on sucks films with area
schedule on the roof of the Empire
Strikes Back businesses report second
Academy Award on the first for mr.
LaMacchia
[Music]
it's only once in a lifetime you get to
recreate Titanic the day I left
Titanic Jim said to me it's been a hell
of a trip believe me it was Jim John ray
and my wife thank you for your support
during the whole production finally I am
only as good as the crew around me
ladies and gentlemen you were the best
thank you I just like to thank two of my
chief prop supports Richard and Barry
without them I think I would have fallen
or drowned I don't which make you young
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]